En este video nos vamos a concentrar en resolver
ejercicios acerca de la pendiente de una recta.
Solo para recordar brevemente, la pendiente es una medida de que tan inclinada se encuentra
una línea recta.
La definición formal de pendiente es,
pendiente es igual al cambio en "y",
entre el cambio en "x".
Esta fórmula puede parecer algo intimidante,
pero por ello vamos a hacer muchos ejemplos
para que se vuelva algo familiar.
Vamos a empezar con esta línea, con la línea a.
Así que vamos a encontrar la pendiente de la línea a.
En esta gráfica ya tenemos marcados dos puntos que podemos usar como nuestros puntos de referencia.
Lo primero que hay que hacer es
encontrar las coordenadas.
¿Cuáles son las coordenadas de este
punto de acá arriba?
Pues su coordenada "x" es 3 y su coordenada "y"es 6.
Ahora, este punto de acá abajo, tiene coordenada "x" -1
y su coordenada "y"es -6.
Hay varias cosas que podríamos hacer para calcular la pendiente de una recta.
La forma más sencilla es usar la fórumla directamente.
El cambio en "y" entre el cambio en "x".
Ahora tenemos que saber,
cuanto valen estas cantidades.
Comencemos con el cambio en "y".
Lo que necesitamos averiguar es cuanto
cambió nuestra coordenada en "y",
al pasar del punto inicial al punto final.
Así que, ¿cuánto cambió nuestra coordenada "y"?
Pues empezamos en -6 y subimos hasta 6 positivo,
así que lo que estamos buscando es esta longitud
y lo que hacemos es tomar el punto "y" final,
la coordenada "y" del punto final y le restamos,
la coordenada "y" del punto inicial -6.
Así es que 6 menos -6, que es lo mismo
que 6 más 6, que es 12.
Por supuesto, también habríamos podido contar en la gráfica... 9, 10, 11, 12.
Así que, el cambio en "y", fue de 12.
Ahora necesitamos saber que cambio de "x"
le corresponde.
Así que,
¿cuánto es el cambio en "x" en este caso?
Pues empezamos en -1 y avanzamos hasta 3,
así que el cambio fue de -1 a 3,
el valor de "x" final fue de 3 y el valor de "x" inicial  fue de -1, así que 3 menos -1, que es 3 más 1, que es 4.
Así que el cambio en "y" entre el cambio en "x" es 12 entre 4 y si simplificamos esta fracción nos da 3.
Ahora, ¿qué quiere decir esto geométricamente?
Pues lo que representa la pendiente, digamos
el cambio en "y" entre el cambio en "x", que
en este caso es 3, que es lo mismo que 3 entre 1,
nos dice que si avanzamos 1 unidad en la
dirección "x" positiva, entonces avanzamos
3 unidades en la dirección "y"positiva.
Es decir, si nos vamos 1 unidad a la derecha,
subimos 3 unidades, 1 a la derecha,
3 unidades hacia arriba.
Y si ahora avanzáramos 2 unidades a la derecha,
entonces subiríamos 6 unidades.
6 entre 2 nos da 3, que de nuevo es la pendiente.
Y lo que nos dice la pendiente,
es que tan rápido crece "y" en relación a "x".
Muy bien, pues ahora continuemos
con el ejemplo de la línea b.
Muy bien, así es que ahora hacemos la línea b.
Voy a usar los puntos que nos dieron aquí,
pero en realidad podría usar cualesquiera
dos puntos sobre la recta.
Vamos a ver, primero este punto que es el
punto 0, 1 y luego este otro punto,
el punto inicial va a ser... es -6, -2.
Así que bueno, la misma idea que antes,
¿cuál es el cambio en "y" para un cambio en "x"?
Primero vamos a hacer el cambio en "x".
Así que, ¿cuál es nuestro cambio en "x"?
Y bueno, aquí en la gráfica podría contar,
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6,
así que el cambio en "x" va a ser 6,
pero imagínense que no tenemos la gráfica, entonces
lo que haríamos es tomamos nuestra posición
"x" terminal o "x" final y le quitamos nuestra
posición de "x" inicial, -6,
así que 0 menos -6, así que nuestro
cambio en "x" es 6 positivo.
¿Y nuestro cambio en "y" cuál es?
Así que, primero que nada, recuerden que
este es nuestro punto final, 0, 1 nuestro punto final
y el -6, -2 es nuestro punto inicial,
así que ahora tenemos que tomar 1 menos -2...
1 menos -2, que es 1 más 2, así que esto nos da 3.
Y por lo tanto, nuestra pendiente es 3/6 ó
lo que es lo mismo, 1/2.
Así es que si nos movemos en la dirección
"x" 6 unidades positivas,
subimos 3 unidades en la dirección "y".
Así que nuestro cambio en "y" fue 3,
nuestro cambio en "x"fue de 6.
Algo que muchas veces confunde a la gente
es, cuál de los dos puntos es el final y cuál es el inicial.
Por ejemplo, como supe tomar este 0
y de ahí restarle el -6
y luego tomar este 1 y de ahí restarle el -2.
La respuesta es que no importa, por ejemplo,
podemos repetir este procedimiento pero ahora
considerando el -6, -2 como nuestro punto final.
Y entonces el cambio en "y"es el valor final de "y" que es -2, menos mi valor inicial en "y" que es 1,
entonces tengo -2 menos 1 y mi valor final de "x" que es -6, menos mi valor inicial de "x" que es 0.
Entonces obtengo lo mismo que antes, solo
que ahora obtengo un signo negativo.
Es decir, -2 menos 1 es -3, dividido entre
-6 menos 0, que es -6
y de nuevo tengo 1/2 porque los menos se cancelan.
Así que, realmente no es importante,
solo hay que ser consistente.
Si considero éste como mi valor de "y" final, entonces éste tiene que ser mi valor de "x" final.
Si ahora considero el 1 como mi valor de "y" final, entonces el 0 debe también ser mi valor de "x" final,
pero si tengo eso en cuenta siempre
obtengo el mismo resultado.
De hecho se puede ver geométricamente, en
este caso, la pendiente, este -6 nos indica
que si recorremos -6 unidades en las "x",
es decir, si nos vamos 6 unidades a la izquierda,
entonces debemos bajar 3 unidades, este -3
de acá y es lo mismo que una pendiente de 1/2,
que nos diría que por cada 2 unidades
que recorro en "x", tengo que subir 1 unidad
o cada 2 unidades hacia atrás tengo que bajar
1 unidad y de nuevo la pendiente es 1/2.
Noten como la recta con pendiente 1/2 es muchísimo
menos inclinada que la recta con pendiente 3.
Muy bien, hagamos un par de ejemplos más.
Vamos a hacer ahora la línea c.
Aquí la línea c la voy a hacer en rosado.
Y de nuevo, voy a tomar los puntos que ya me dieron sobre la línea, voy a usar este punto y este punto.
Mi punto inicial es el -1, 6
y mi punto final es 5... 5, -6... 5, -6.
Entonces bueno, ¿cuánto vale nuestra pendiente?
¿cuánto vale la pendiente de la recta?
Entonces el cambio en "y"... el cambio en "y"
entre el cambio en "x" y esto a veces
se llama el alza entre el avance,
el avance es el avance en la dirección "x" y el alza
es cuanto subimos en la dirección "y".
Entonces bueno, nuestro cambio en "y", es
nuestra coordenada "y" final
menos nuestra coordenada en "y" inicial.
Así que esta es nuestra coordenada "y" final
y esta es nuestra coordenada en "y" inicial,
sobre nuestra coordenada "x" final
entre nuestra coordenada "x" inicial.
Y realmente lo único que estoy diciendo
es que esto vale -6 menos 6, entre nuestra coordenada
"x" final que es 5
menos nuestra coordenada "x" inicial que es -1.
Así que esto nos da -6 menos 6 es -12,
entre 5 menos -1 se vuelve 6, entonces -12
entre 6 que es lo mismo que -2.
Así que la pendiente es -2 y esto se debe
a que cada vez que avanzo uno en la dirección "x",
tengo que bajar 2 en la dirección "y",
así que esto es una pendiente negativa
y significa que la línea va de la esquina superior
izquierda a la esquina inferior derecha,
así que podemos pensar que mientras
la "x" crece, la "y" decrece.
Con este razonamiento, la línea "d" debería
de tener una pendiente positiva.
De nuevo uso estos dos puntos que ya me dieron,
así que vamos a hacer la línea "d"...
la pendiente es igual al alza entre el avance,
¿cuánto me alcé y cuánto avancé
al pasar de este punto al otro?
Pues ¿alcé o subí, cuántas unidades?
2, 3, 4, 5, 6 unidades.
Mi avance es de 6 unidades, y cuánto...
perdón, mi alza es de 6 unidades...
¿Y cuánto es mi avance?
Mi avance es 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Mi avance es de 6,
así que nuestra pendiente es 6 entre 6, debe ser 1 y eso nos dice que cada vez que avanzo 1 en la dirección "x",
subo 1 en la dirección "y".
Y si digamos, lo que hiciera fuera retroceder,
retrocedo 2 unidades entonces bajo 2 unidades.
Entonces, lo que hagamos en "x"
lo tenemos que hacer en "y".
Así que esta recta estuvo bastante sencilla.
Si quisiéramos hacerlo formalmente, matemáticamente,
entonces tendríamos que encontrar
las coordenadas de estos puntos.
Nuestro punto inicial sería el -2, -4
y nuestro punto final sería el 4, 2... 4, 2.
Y entonces nuestra pendiente es el cambio en "y" entre el cambio en "x" y eso es lo mismo que 2 menos -4 entre,
4 menos -2... -2.
Así es que esto nos da 2 menos -4 es 2 más 4  que es 6 y eso es simplemente la distancia
que recorrí en la dirección "y" entre 4 menos -2 que es otro 6 y esto nos da la pendiente de 1.
Muy bien, vamos a hacer otro ejemplo.
Éste está bastante interesante,
vamos a hacer la línea "e", esta línea.
Y bueno, el cambio en "y" entre el cambio en "x", queremos encontrar la pendiente.
¿Cuánto vale nuestro cambio en "y"
al movernos de ese punto a ese punto?
Pues si lo contamos es, 5, 6, 7, 8... 8 unidades
o podríamos tomar simplemente esta coordenada
"y" que es 2 menos esta coordenada "y" que es -6,
que es 2 menos -6, que es 8.
¿Y cuál es el cambio en "x"?
Pues nuestro valor de "x" aquí es 4, y nuestro valor de "x" aquí es 4, así que no hubo cambio en "x",
el cambio en "x" es 0, entonces
¿cuánto vale 8 entre 0?
Pues realmente no está definido, así que
en este caso cuando tenemos una línea vertical,
decimos que la pendiente está indefinida.
Entonces si la pendiente está indefinida,
lo que pasa es que no hay cambio en "x" y
podemos decir que se trata de una línea vertical.
Bien, pues vamos a hacer este último ejemplo,
el de la línea "f".
Y este se ve bastante sencillo.
Entonces tengo ese punto, que tiene coordenadas
3, 1, la línea "f" y tengo el punto 3, 1 y también tengo este otro punto que tiene coordenadas -6, -2.
Ahora, ¿cuánto vale la pendiente de la línea "f"?
Pues como siempre es el cambio en "y" entre el cambio en "x", ahora para hacer las cosas distintas,
voy a tomar el -6, -2 como mi punto final.
Entonces el cambio en "y", ahora es un descenso y vale -2 menos 1, eso es mi "y" final menos mi "y" inicial.
-2 menos 1 que es -3.
Y ahora tengo que dividir entre el cambio en "x",
pero el cambio en "x" ahora es un
retroceso, es un retroceso
¿de cuántas unidades?
Como tomé el -2, como mi valor final de "y",
ahora tengo que tomar el -6 como mi "x" final,
entonces -6 menos 3 y esto vale -9, entonces
tengo una pendiente de -3 entre -9 y lo que
significa es que, si retrocedo 9 unidades,
si me voy 9 unidades a la izquierda, entonces
bajo 3 unidades, que es exactamente lo mismo
que decir, si avanzo 9 unidades subo 3, los
menos se cancelan y obtengo una pendiente
de 1/3, así que la pendiente es positiva
y como siempre significa que si avanzo 3 unidades
a la derecha, entonces subo 1 unidad... subo 1.
Si avanzo 3 a la derecha entonces subo 1.
Y bueno, espero que esto haya sido un buen repaso de los conceptos de pendiente.